hello I'm psychedelically andrew heaton
and you're tripping on some flame Oh
mostly weekly interesting
so last week Jeff Sessions decided that
facing his snowpocalypse nuclear
annihilation and ongoing White House
investigations now is a good time to
crack down on pot sessions is rescinding
an Obama era memo keeping federal
prosecutors from charging people for
marijuana crimes and states which have
already legalized it oh but how can I be
mad at that face there's a notion that
drug use is rare in the drug users fall
into two basic categories there's the
dangerous crazy drug addict from an
after-school special man everybody grows
apart or the lazy dumb stoner type from
a Cheech and Chong film but drugs are a
complex issue and it's important to have
a real conversation about them you can
have your opinion about drugs and which
should be legal but drug use isn't rare
a national survey on drug use and health
estimates that forty eight point five
percent of all Americans over the age of
12 have used an illicit drug at least
once a more conservative estimate by the
Mayo Clinic still says at least twenty
percent and that number is rising drug
use is accelerating in certain unseemly
and dangerous demographics I am of
course talking about the affluent the
baby boomers and the women so when you
picture a drug user think Meryl Streep
control totally but it's not just the
overrated actresses of the world in fact
many of the most beloved and cherished
icons of history ingested snorted smoked
and injected drugs don't believe me well
[ __ ] you here's a list Winston Churchill
amphetamines that's right
Winston goddamn bowtie rocking jowls
having Nazi punching Churchill after a
stroke in 1953 then Prime Minister
Winston Churchill was prescribed dren ml
part barbiturate partum Fett amine and a
hundred percent illegal by today's
standards not only did Churchill drink
heavily
he used amphetamines like a Phi Beta
Kappa the night before finals Churchill
even had affectionate nicknames for the
drug cocktails like greens Reds majors
minors and lured morons in honor of his
script happy doctor in fact in 1942 lady
astor reportedly quipped Winston you're
ugly to which Churchill rejoined are my
teeth falling out I've got to clean this
house had Winston
been caught with that type of in feda
mean today and had he then prosecuted to
the fullest extent of the law he would
have received up to a year in prison and
Thomas cocaine long before cocaine
became the drug choice for suspenders
clad eighties banker dick bags cocaine
made its way into the hands of America's
most beloved inventory Edison drankin
and a popular wine and became a big
advocate claiming cocaine boosted his
powers of perception Edison's drug use
might explain why the guy had over 1093
patents who else could have had the
energy to invent a crank powered
phonograph other than some coked out guy
wanting to drop a beat had Thomas Edison
been caught with cocaine today and had
he been prosecuted to the fullest extent
of the law he would have been charged
with a felony and served three years in
prison Steve Jobs LSD Steve Jobs
turtleneck icon and founder of some
Fruit Company took LSD and spoke quite
openly about its importance in his life
and career
according to jobs taking LSD was a
profound experience one of the most
important things in my life according to
his friend and co-worker that LSD had
been a very positive transformation in
heavy thought sounds like there was a
little fire between you two jobs would
have served 1 to 5 years in prison for
possession and possible intent to
distribute
had he been prosecuted to the fullest
extent of the law gertrude stein
marijuana american poet playwright and
brooch sensation Gertrude Stein was a
nonconformist of many stripes in
particular her loose attitude towards
drug use
Stein's life partner Alice B toklas even
went so far as to write a best-selling
cookbook that included you guessed it a
recipe for pot brownies if Stein or her
partner Alice were caught in one of 28
states and had she been prosecuted to
the fullest extent of the law Jeff
Sessions could have thrown her into the
clinker eyeing land amphetamines you
might have mixed feelings about ein rant
[Music]
but she did consume amphetamines don't
believe me how else do you think Atlas
Shrugged got to be a 1168 page doorstop
in 1942 Rand was prescribed Benzedrine a
type of amphetamine to lose weight but
instead she found that speed helped her
books to gain weight
she took the drug to finish the
fountainhead an average day chapter to
week she was such a fan she's
nymphetamine for 30 years and if ran
were caught with that kind of speed
today she would have served a year in
prison Thomas Jefferson opium Thomas
Jefferson is famous for the Louisiana
Purchase the Declaration of Independence
and embarrassingly owning people in his
latter years Jefferson drank laudanum to
ease his bowels and do you know what the
principal ingredient of laudanum is show
me opium and had Jefferson been caught
with opium today and had he been
prosecuted to the fullest extent of the
law he would have served a year in
prison and drug use is so common among
former US presidents it's practically a
requirement for the job here's a quick
list of every president who did drugs
[Music]
maybe it's why the most common drug use
device is their face those are just a
few famous and beloved people who did
drugs and so here are a few others we
didn't have time for Carl Sagan actually
a big proponent of legalizing pot
Benjamin Franklin even more of a rascal
and Cary Grant and just for fun here are
a few obvious ones
[Music]
and finally mr. Rogers Neil deGrasse
Tyson and Alf did not do drugs but what
if you found out they had would it
render their accomplishments less
valuable would it change your admiration
for Alf no I'm not saying that drugs are
good or bad drug use can be incredibly
harmful in the hands of an addict but
drug policy is a complex issue with
serious consequences so let's have a
real conversation about drugs we're not
doing any favors by reducing the
national conversation to a cornball PSA
the burning weed with its roots in hell
how much did you guys smoke
[Applause]
[Music]